let's take a look at a cloud state
kotlin example that uses the light bend
cloud state service to run this on the
cloud
and you can find the source code on
github
james ward cloud state sample fraud
okay first let's take a look at the code
so with cloud state we use
protobufs to model the messages that
we're going to send
and then the rpc operations that will be
performed
so we have a transaction with a
timestamp amount location and just
description and then we have a user
transaction
that associates that with a cloud state
entity key which allows us to do the
partitioning
of the messages and that also gives us
the ability to
scale this thing up and down
horizontally based on
uh what's happening the messages as
they're being partitioned
okay and then we have a way to add the
transaction a user transaction
and get transactions let's take a look
at the activity entity and
this is where the logic for handling
those messages
happens so we've got an event sourced
entity
and then you can see there's a
constructor argument with the user id
which is our partitioning key so that's
how we're able to
partition this data in this class we
have
our transactions which is our mutable
list and so whenever we get transaction
messages coming in then we're going to
be able to add them to this list so that
we have our accumulated state here in
this entity
then we have a command handler for add
transaction which takes that user
transaction
and then we also get a context command
context with there
and then we can have our logic for
detecting fraud on a transaction
so whenever a new transaction comes in
we're going to use the past data
and the new transaction to calculate
the velocity and so there's obviously
lots of different ways that we would
calculate
compute whether or not the transaction
is potentially fraudulent
for this simple example i'm just using
velocity
and if the user's velocity goes over a
max velocity
then we're going to say that there's
possible fraud and in this case we're
just going to output to that to the
console
but then once we have potentially
detected the potential fraud
we are going to emit a message which
says okay we've done our handling of
this message
and then that event handler will trigger
this will go on to an event log
which is persisted in spanner in google
cloud spanner
okay so that's the the bulk of the
entity processing
i've got a little class that just starts
up the server and then i've got a
simulator class that is going to
simulate some transactions so let's go
over and run this now i already have
this up and running
on google cloud via the
lightbend cloud state service but let's
go start up the simulator
and what this will do is start adding a
bunch of transactions to this
transaction log
and what we'll be able to do once this
starts emitting those messages we'll be
able to see the messages that are being
emitted
here in the console and then we'll go
over to google cloud logging
to actually see if we get a potential
fraud so here we go that we're now
feeding a bunch of transactions into
that system the we've got multiple
users so we're doing partitioning of the
data for that entity
and now here in cloud the log
viewer in google cloud now we can see
the server messages
from my entity that's running up on uh
google cloud and
lightbend cloud state so let's go
try to jump to now and see there we go
okay so it looks like we just got
a possible fraud alert and we can see
the user id the merchant
the amount when it happened and then the
google
map link to where that transaction was
and
if we let this continue running we
probably will see some more potential
fraud
alerts coming in as that simulator runs
so you can see we're feeding in tons of
messages they're partitioned based on
user id
so we get the ability to auto scale this
service
up and down and that's that's great for
something like this where the amount of
transactions that are coming in is going
to fluctuate
throughout the day with probably more
transactions happening
in the morning and evening i would guess
and less at night
and so so great we can scale our service
automatically
based on that there's a container image
that i built
and deployed which contains my
entity code okay so that's the quick
example
of cloud state running on the light bend
cloud state
service